irgendwann muss an
er saß auf blieben der frau finden also
ja also ich von mir aus nie ein grund
wunsch
und dann hat sie die donau kann erklärt
sofort verliebt mai wurde jetzt sage es
im vorverkauf im board ist sie aber früh
ab weil wir die mitte zieht dann
vorsichtig wie im herzen erfahrungen
gemacht mit anderen brauche man dank der
das front office warte aus welchem grund
auch immer noch kann er nicht wie
gelingt es uns die hoffnung nicht zu
verlieren dass es irgendwo auf der welt
einen menschen gibt der uns lieben kann
davon handelt dieser film
[Musik]
diese mann markus speziell das fängt bei
seinem selbst gewählten fantasie
vornamen crash an geht über seine äußere
erscheinung und wird in wenigen stunden
vorerst hier enden mit einer keltischen
trauung unter freiem himmel
vor zwei jahren treffe ich mag die
baltischen bruchs zum ersten mal einen
mann der von sich sagt ihm sei egal was
andere von ihm denken
das gänzlich ungeniert beleben hat
allerdings seinen preis
er verbringt viel zeit alleine
dass es menschen gibt die in blech und
stört martin nicht dass er für frauen
offenbar höchstens als kollege in frage
kommt beginnt ihm mit mitte dreißig
allerdings zuzusetzen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wie schätzen sie denn selber mehr traf
warum will aber wenn man mich erst nach
aschermittwoch wo frau vor allem wo man
das besser kennenlernen tanz auf seinen
namen mit dir war es mit die retter
nicht alleine gestanden war dunkel ist
und das ist meistens das große problem
mit said ramadan scheiße lebens aber
dass man ruft idee und ausdrucke pflicht
gegenüber format beträgt andere alte
frau auf der straße hilft auf die idee
und das bild anstatt das macht bekennt
muss erst einen 15 uhr geht es auf der
suche nach liebe richtung osten
im wissen dass dort nicht alles besser
ist und in der hoffnung dass er sich
vielleicht täuscht mit dem honig schon
kontakt aufgenommen
also zweiten mal e-mails austauscht
sagte ihnen dass ich fahrerisch das ist
für sie eine gute ausgangslage für
gemeinsame zukunft ja die gleichen
hobbys gleichen interessen frau wo alle
auf dem tiefpunkt weiß wie suppen zu und
her geht und du musst mit gerade mal
fünf minuten vor spielende ins gesicht
auftragen
[Musik]
im mai 2012 30 mit martin auch kiew wo
er auf seiner virtuellen bekanntschaft
eine wirkliche machen will
hmm
[Musik]
du hast mir doch geschrieben dass du mal
ein itf tut oder europa machen möchte
das ist erst ein clown oder besser
gesagt so etwas wie ein traum
[Gelächter]
london ist 31 und arbeitet als
designerin
sie ist ihrem äußeren erscheinungsbild
zum trotz schüchtern und ein wenig
unsicher genau wie martin und auch sie
mag motorräder die keltische kultur
fantasiewelten und heavy metal musik ist
populär bei uns jetzt mental auf will
kill you
mit anderen worten ich werde dich töten
in diesem zusammenhang offenbar aus
einer art balzgesang zu verstehen
ich habe den eindruck dass für viele
gemeinsame interessen haben uns gehen
die themen nie aus
bevor nicht gesehen
[Musik]
vielleicht das so ist
selbst
wir verbinden
1600 km gereist für diese eine flüchtige
begegnung und für die hoffnung dass das
kein ende sondern ein anfang gewesen ist
[Musik]
wenn nicht eine wo anfang macht oder zu
laut ich halte es eben auf distanz
blieben vorsichtig und die klinik vielen
möglichst kontrollieren bevor
[Musik]
zwei jahre späteres marty immer noch
unterwegs allerdings nicht mehr alleine
[Musik]
zwei menschen sind dabei ihre rüstungen
abzulegen und sich eine chance zu geben
[Musik]
machnig zu viel das leben jetzt hier in
der schweiz mit crash ist das so wie sie
es sich vorher vorgestellt haben
ja hätte vorstellen können wirklich
funktioniert die unsicherheit hat sich
gleich ob sie bleibt alles richtig mache
sie zufrieden ich mit mir die
unsicherheit dank wird und wenn sie der
band ist paramo natürlich tritt 23
vielleicht wird sie auch noch bliebe
[Musik]
schnitzlers für sie wird die partnerin
zu haben
die macht das gleiche täglichen stellige
also ich will kleinen schönste was haben
sie sich verliebt ist ganz toll ist wie
sie ist wirklich und wenn man die
teilweise auch kleider ist wirklich drin
saßen
wo aber auch krebs masse kann also mit
bis dato nie wieder genau das gesagt an
amazon kürzer sind
eine amazonen princess sind die auch im
schottenrock eine gute figur macht und
die ihre samstage ebenfalls gerne auf
einem mittelalterfest im luzernischen
rickenbach verbringt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
interessant wie ein mädchen
eine automatische enklave in der es
weder lastwagenfahrer noch designerinnen
gibt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
was fällt ihnen nicht zu warm und das
ist durchaus fasziniert ja denn so ist
das wohl aber die kommen schon fünf
besten seite
alle menschen stark und was werden sie
für eine figur in dieser zahlen
eine krise ist so wie sie sind noch 1 10
meter mensch sie sind doch ein
siebenmeter friedliche menschen vor dem
fernsehen ja und so stellt realität ist
sie eine krise den sesseln und sagt
weißt du hin zum 1
[Applaus]
das wirklich so ausgebucht volk in der
post
laut marquardt weiter szene spruch
nächstes buch kostet ob sie sind ja alle
zehn und sensible mannschaften für aus
sensibel
[Applaus]
die röhre geschaut dass hier brachte vor
mitternacht hat aber nie gedacht dann
kriegt da muss ich darauf nacht
nacheinander setzten aber es sind kann
man schon zum beispiel die angst davor
verlässlich ja wenn ich schon nicht
eigens wurden irgendwelche verletzungen
körperlich oder seelisch 0 1 wo immer
der heime ist ein cover lässigen
in der realität des alltags verbringt
die lohner szabo nun ihre meiste zeit
auf der suche nach einer neuen rolle
viel freie zeit ein bisschen zu viel wie
nie langweilig sind sie nie einsam
sie designt rezepte und stellt sich sind
internet neudeutsch nennt sich das food
blog eine referenz an ihr früheres leben
das iaaf gegeben hat für die liebe ist
gut
wir haben vieles was der canon machen
zusammen in unserer freizeit
das ist interessant
ist ein liebermann
inzwischen wurden sie auf dem
zivilstandsamt weil es sein musste damit
sie beieinander bleiben können ein rein
bürokratische akt sei es gewesen finden
beide nicht weiter der rede wert hat
kein fleisch und trainer
ich kann noch gar nicht
103 diese ausschnitte von g zwischen
ukraine
das gilt mehr ukrainische wie hoch sie
hofft mit sehr viel mühe mit jedem
gemeinsamen schritt trauen sie sich es
ein bisschen mehr zu glauben das was in
einer singlebörse im internet angefangen
hat könnte tatsächlich liebe werden und
ihren leben eine ganz neue richtung
geben so flugplatz flüge und jetzt kommt
sogar spazieren
ich habe frau die hütte wo seine gemacht
sprich hoch bis auf asche das stehen die
nachricht wenn ich zufall bin nicht
besitzt so wie sie selbst vorstellen
kann
ich habe gearbeitet
viele jahre machen kann hier und heute
ich wähle machen familie haben ein
schönes man vielleicht besser kinder und
dabei und so hört die welt für einen
moment auf sich zu drehen in einem wald
oberhaut von stans im engsten
familienkreis erholen und normal oder
eigentlich schon immer so
da haben wir noch sehr flach pc logisch
also dass rutten herrscht freude meine
liebe schöne tochter ilona liebe crash
ich wünsche euch viel liebe glück
zufriedenheit und kinder
ich war überrascht dass meine kleine
schwester einen schweizer heiratet aber
ich freue mich dass sich die beiden
gefunden haben in dieser großen feld
[Musik]
ich freue mich dass meine tochter nun in
der schweiz ein neues leben anfangen
kann
in einem sicheren land weit weg von
krieg
[Musik]
magst du fillion hat das feuer sein dass
ihr wärme spendet und magst du ihr das
wasser geben damit sie nie mehr das muss
so antworte mit ihrem linkskurs 11
noch vor meinem herrn gehe ich auf dich
die gebe ihm ein teil von mir
sind sie glücklich wenn ich das sagen
würde was ich mir ist wichtig ständig an
grund sein und sie sind sie glücklich
[Musik]